as you wake up in the West we're
breaking news that is still unfolding in
Washington police in the capital
arrested a man this morning on weapons
charges inside the Trump International
Hotel near the White House sources tell
CBS News the man is from Pennsylvania
the guns and ammunition in question were
in his car Julianna Goldman is outside
the Trump Hotel with what we know so far
Julianna good morning good morning as
you can see behind me here at the Trump
Hotel the scene is now clear but we are
learning more details about what
happened earlier this morning the man
who was arrested with heavily armed he
had an assault rifle a Glock handgun and
ammunition was also found in his car DC
police got a tip that this man was on
his way to Washington DC police are
handling the investigation and they're
being helped partnered with federal
authorities including the Secret Service
the motive of this man is unknown but we
do know that since Donald Trump became
president
there have been security concerns at his
properties not just here blocks from the
White House around the country and also
around the world were waiting more
information from DC police they'll be
holding a press conference later this
morning to update us on the
investigation so far Julianna thank you